[Music]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and you
may remember you may have seen the end
of my galaxy note 7 review where i
mentioned if you have a pre-recall
galaxy note 7 that was exploding you
should return it but if you have a post
recall galaxy note 7 one of the
replacements with the green battery
then you're good and then we saw a story
of a replacement galaxy note 7 going up
in smoke and catching fire on a plane
okay so well you know maybe it could
just be a fluke sometimes phones have
flukes or maybe actually it could have
just been a non-replacement galaxy note
7 and somebody just said it was because
they're trying to drum up a headline or
something and then there was another one
and another one and another one
replacement galaxy note 7s are now
catching fire and exploding everywhere
so the bottom line is this phone the
galaxy note 7 is not safe so if you have
a note 7 old or new green battery or
white battery original or replacement
for your safety and for the safety of
those around you you should return it
and samsung has acknowledged this and
they have stopped selling note 7
completely worldwide rip note 7. so
let's say you had a galaxy note 7 and
you really liked that phone i mean it
was a great phone it had a great display
great camera great set of features high
end specs great build what's not to love
i mean it was a nice phone before it
started exploding and that was nice
enough to get people to spend a lot of
money on it so what do you do now these
are in order of similarity the best
replacements for the galaxy note 7 so
the most similar to that phone so if you
had a note 7 or if you were thinking
about getting a note 7 these are the
best alternatives that won't explode
number one is the samsung galaxy s7 edge
this physically speaking is as close as
you're going to get it's like the
obvious choice and it loses the fewest
features from the note 7. so you still
get a big bright gorgeous amoled display
you still have the exact same camera
nearly identical software with the
samsung ui on top of android just minus
the iris scanner and secure folder
feature and a few minor things you do
lose the stylus but you actually get a
bigger battery than the note so if you
love the note you will love this this is
the equivalent of like a brother as far
as products in samsung's lineup goes
number two is the regular samsung galaxy
s7 not the edge so this is a little bit
of a further drop off and you lose a
couple more features you don't get as
big of a display or as big of a battery
you don't get the edge display features
from the rounded sides of the galaxy s7
edge but the thing is there's almost no
reason to get the regular s7 if you were
on board with the s7 edge other than
maybe you discovered that your hands are
too small to use a big phone suddenly or
you just don't like having a big phone
anymore in that case the galaxy s7 is
gonna do almost all the same things but
for most people you should still do the
s7 edge all right so number three is the
iphone 7 plus so obviously this is now
going a little bit outside the family
but before you go crazy the iphone 7
plus is actually a really top-notch
phone and it keeps up in a lot of the
ways that the note 7 was really good the
note 7 was a great high-end large phone
and iphone 7 plus is another great
high-end large phone you'll still have a
great battery life you still have a
great camera and you'll still have water
resistance too it's not quad hd super
amoled display but it's easily the best
1080p display in any smartphone so it
still looks pretty good and you'll
actually be keeping a lot of the super
high end hardware and performance and
features by picking up a seven plus now
i don't know how many early adopter
super enthusiast note 7 buyers would
drop everything and buy an iphone ios is
obviously very different from android
but this is definitely still a rock
solid choice and the full review is
incoming for that too so number four is
the lg v20 so this is a phone that was
actually competing directly against the
note 7 in a lot of ways for your money
so it should be a very similar
experience so i've talked about it more
in a second video but this is a phone
that's flying under the radar as far as
great high-end big smartphones go and
it's definitely big no doubting that
bigger footprint even than the note 7
itself but when you consider you get
that big removable battery something the
note 7 obviously didn't have expandable
storage a great camera or pair of
cameras like the iphone 7 plus a really
exceptional dac for great audio and that
unique second display up top for
notifications and saving you screen real
estate on the main display there's a lot
going for it it's not water resistant
and obviously lg is packing a very
different set of features on top of
android than samsung is there's no s pen
but no other phone has an s pen so i
think as far as big android phones go
you probably can't really go wrong with
lg v20 to replace a phone that was
competing against so number five is a
bit more of a wild card but it's the
google pixel xl and this probably
couldn't be a much better time for this
phone to come out of the heat of a lot
of people coming out of the note 7. for
the larger of the two phones running
pure stock android 7.1 out the box a lot
of people haven't been paying much
attention to it or giving it much credit
but the pixel xl is shaping up to be a
pretty good big phone replacement now
the caveat is it's not out right now so
depending on when you watch this there
could be a gap between when you order it
and when you get it or not but if you
can get your hands on a google pixel xl
it's shaping up to look like a pretty
good high-end smartphone but you will be
missing some features right off the gate
the pixel isn't water resistant it
doesn't have expandable storage it
doesn't have any of the samsung features
on top of android obviously there's no
stylus the camera is sort of unproven at
this point it may or may not be as good
it'll probably match performance it's
got that snapdragon 821 chip inside but
this is more of a distant cousin despite
being such a big high-end phone of
course there are other big great phones
there's moto z force there's htc 10
there's even cheaper ones but or you
could even go with the galaxy note 5 if
you just have to have that s pen i mean
obviously there's other phones coming
out but no other phone is going to come
out that has that stylus that s pen
experience so if you gotta have the
stylus then maybe you go back to note 5
for the time being
either way the phones i've listed above
are the ones that are closest in
similarity to the one that we miss and
loved so dearly minus the explosions
until then rip note 7 it was a great
phone it really was but it's gonna be
missed it's a shame and until then on to
the next one thanks for watching i'll
talk to you guys the next one peace
[Music]